afternoon councillors welcome along to
our may meeting and just please remain
standing for the opening prayer father
we just give you thanks
for the privilege that you've bestowed
upon us to
deliberate on the fears relating to this
community both today and tomorrow and we
just pray for wisdom as we work through
the agenda today
you ask these things in jesus name amen
so welcome councillors to
[Music]
our may
council meeting
we have um
one
apology councillor bulger who's unable
to be with us and we have two attending
on zoom so councillor grant
and councillor dixon so welcome along to
um to both good to have you here
would somebody like to move that apology
be sustained please thank you do i have
a second for that
council phillips thank you all those in
favor please say aye
gates the motion is carried
is there any conflicts of interest that
councillors need to declare at this
point in the proceedings
nikki
okay
okay
noted
right
confirmation of minutes and reports
um and we have the confirmation of the
minutes of the ordinary medium council
held
tuesday 12 april would somebody like to
move that be seen
as true and correct please
councillor heisted uh do i have a
seconder for that
councillor grant thank you
is there any alteration required to that
set of minutes
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye against
the motion is carried thank you
councillors
is there any urgent late business that
hasn't been notified
there's not thank you
right we'll move on to uh item five uh
creative communities assessment
committee and we have a um
a series of minutes uh or a set of
minutes from that particular committee
um
would somebody like to move that that
report
be received please counselor davis thank
you
dr secondary counselor reid thank you
is there any discussion on those minutes
does not thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
right
we have a report with regard to proposed
traffic and parking improvements on
ardwick street
adjacent to the new library and
community centre
and we have a report here from
our parks and recreation manager keith
and i'll just ask you keith if you
wouldn't mind talking council through
this particular report and
we'll open it for discussion do you want
to make any comments at this point
you may need to speak into a microphone
keith
for the people on zoom to be able to
hear
touch it again
just need to touch it again
yeah
just briefly yeah okay
um through your worship the mia um it
was some
comments to make about the
uh plans that were
put forward
initially
the the roading manager
peter
sandering
started this work and we've just really
carried her on there now with his
departure
so parks wouldn't normally be talking on
roading but
essentially the work
has come come about really as um
was it some discussion about the new
building and the planting around that
building and then uh it was a sort of
the linkage made with the
surrounding street and some issues that
occurred when the library used to be
located
in the james coming wing so um
i think we've sort of taken some
comments on board from
i guess the parties within council
and um the proposal uh is really just to
uh narrow the uh
the carriageway uh in in front of a new
build so down ardell street um it would
starting um to the north with some
planters on the uh bowler and artwork
street corner
um and then
as we come down some
some planting
through the
angled car parking
currently
there's a
double lined
median strip down the middle of the
street and um
the the thought is that we would push
the main carriage way over slightly
towards the school
we gain about another
meter meter and a half behind
where the current uh angled car parking
is so that
it makes makes it safer for people
backing out of those car parks
um
i guess the other key features really
are the um
i think previously it was issues with
campervans um parking in front of the
library when it was located there and um
uh volbe specifically excluded from
those angled car parks
um i'm just trying to think what else is
there um
are the parking in front of a school and
also the church um
currently there's a there's a line down
the side of a road um but there's no
delineation car park so um so it's um
the idea is that we'll delineate the car
parks and get a better um
i guess a more efficient use of those
car parking spaces
um i'm just trying to think what else on
the list um
yeah we've had some preliminary
discussions with uh senior citizens and
the school
and both were very much in favor of the
crossing um in in front of the
new building
and um
i think that senior citizens have
previously asked for that so that
they're
very much in favor of that
just in terms of the drawings um
there has been a wee bit of artistic
license and
i guess in terms of the planting and
things like that uh the intent is that
the planting will be very low so there's
no um
sight lines will be good throughout the
site and
the plantings will kind of match
plantings that are around the new
building as well so there is sort of a
nice continuity
i think the other thing that was on
there was that um
i did just the use of a bit of street
furniture i think the intent is to have
uh a couple of seats out in front of a
new library but also across the road so
that there will be options for people on
a sunny day to
uh if you're waiting for
you know kids from school or whatever
but you know it'll be a
pedestrian friendly
situation right okay
so from here before i opened up from
discussion
um you know
if it goes from here uh unaltered from
by council so what's the intention then
keith to talk to the users around here
just
confirming um
what that process might be uh we've had
a preliminary discussion with the school
and and the and the senior citizens and
both were
firmly in favor but um i think we we
would have a formal sit down with them
really just to make sure that um
they're comfortable with all the aspects
and you know there might be just some
little little details that need to be
changed just to kind of cater for their
um
for their requirements
and i guess uh by when you say the
school you're concluding the church so
no no we we haven't we haven't talked to
the church
over contact with the church and uh
we haven't talked to the bus company who
are probably um
well they could be it could be impacted
by this but okay
hello councillors um
open for discussion council read
thank you your worship um just
looks great on paper doesn't it but um i
did have a wee query on one of the
drawings there at the end of bowler ave
opposite the church there's a red line i
wondered what that was
or what what it was indicating
i think
speed hump
no no i i
i think that's uh that's an error
actually looking at that i like there's
there's certainly no intention to put
anything like that in there
so would there be um
i know that that corner when traffic
comes down they tend to
what's around the corner to the left
um is there any opportunity to look at
perhaps having a compulsory stop there
um i i would suggest you something
yeah i realized yeah i like the the
comment murray has made to me regarding
um all of these plans you know we
haven't we haven't proof tested it um
you know i think the council generally
tries to follow the new zealand car park
and roading standards so um
we would have to apply that to all of
this to make sure that there is um
yeah there is some safety around the
corners and things that is a
particularly bad corner it would be
really good but given the amount of
traffic in the area that it's
fixed before we start yeah thank you
council macphail then council phillips
oh yes thank you your worship um
just having a view through it are the
number of parks that are there
and whether everything's
fit for purpose and particularly around
doing roading changes within the current
environment um
obviously the big thing would be
consultation with that grant street as
well
um i know with some of the roading
changes that we've made
previously that consultation
didn't go correctly so what we're going
to make sure
is that everyone knows exactly what's
going on and what's what's the proposed
um
layout and setup is going to be
um and the other thing is obviously open
to change
if we accept the concept
that's on there we've obviously got
20 um
25
parks along the front there um it's
still
when they went round
i don't know where you're gonna be i've
asked to answer the question keith but
when they went around and checked the
old library with the parking area and
the precinct there
is that the same number that we've got
there the same
capacity that we have for parking people
up
uh i think it is
plus you've also got a number of um
extra parks or parking in front of the
civic ave there so that the only thing
just checking that we still have
capacity to park there other than that i
support the plan i think it's um it's
there it's a concept um hopefully it's
going to be fit for purpose make sure we
do the consultation and also have the
ability to change or be away but nimble
around it if it's not working
council phillips and then i think
council grant on zoom
thank you worship i just got a couple of
questions keith um excuse my back
just the um
i shouldn't think that we should um
the car parking for
um campervans we should try and find a
space for camper vans and i think
the
parking
on civic air arbor street corner could
be possibly used for that the first
carpark and be signed up as a car park
for
camper vans it's quite a large park
and the other concern i have is the exit
in entry
for the park for the school with the
buses coming in and out i don't think
if you're looking towards the new
library
the exit and the car park beside it on
the left hand side if were driving a bus
i don't think you would
go out there if there's a car parked
there without crossing the oncoming
traffic so i think that needs to look at
and also coming in as well
just uh just to point that out
you know that's
okay so some good points there so i
think both of them are well worth noting
um councillor grant if you had a
point
thank you
uh
uh justin before i'm just a bit uh
amused on my news but the fact that the
working group has been set up in
uh of council offices and including the
creative conference architects is here
has he landscaped marketing for a
and also
um yeah thanks your worship
the key consideration for the council
was the time was marching on and what we
wanted to do is at least get
some collection of ideas and we
certainly and it was done before the
departure of peter standering so we had
his input into the process as well
it was never the intention to have a
presenter fatigue but to present um
from the
professional view of and the into the
library's manager was involved along
with keith mcroby and peter standering
to present a starting point for
discussion and to present it in a visual
form
as opposed to a project brief so that we
can then get it out to interested
parties key stakeholders for for comment
and i believe that is an appropriate way
in terms of the the professional
expertise that the staff have in their
respective disciplines to get
a
considered balanced view as a starting
point for discussion and then obviously
on to the council and then
the wider community but certainly the
council was always and i met i made that
point to declare to the working party
the first protocol before we actually
then
reached out to key stakeholders in the
wider community
i think it's appropriate that to be
accounting
a counselor involved along the way and
and doug has suggested neville i'm not
sure whether neil's uh willing for that
or not
yeah that'd be fine
okay great thank you
and look i'm sure you were open to that
to
keith yes certainly sorry i didn't give
much choice um yeah i i was just going
to make a comment about the use of um
greg moffat too really the the reason he
was used really was um
the the plan drawing was is
one-dimensional and they've got the
ability because of produced material for
the um
the new library complex that they could
they can produce something in 3d so it
was
it was just you it was utilizing those
skills uh we weren't using any design
skills other other than that
and just another question i think you
asked doug about the person that was
involved in the streets live um sony did
you have a comment about that
uh through the chair um
no we didn't um i think i used my cuts
because they've been involved the
project right along and were aware of
what the requirements were so there's no
connection between the two no there
isn't no okay
okay um
yeah stuart
um my question is how much this will be
taught at time parking lot
out in front of the library obviously
it'd be 60 minutes or 90 minutes but
grant street if residents want to park
there we can't make that
90-minute parking or
and we don't want if you leave it
with no parking limits
then council staff or other people could
park here and take up all these parks
so there's a whether you do residents
only parking in some of this area
or residents have a disc and they can
stay longer you need to work out
something streets in dunedin where
you can only park 60 minutes but
residents can park all day because
they've got a disc in their window of
their car
so we need to look at something like
that too
so is that um that being considered
keith yeah i think we're like we've
deliberately treated grant street as a
quiet residential street and and you
know i think i think that's the intent
to for that to remain that way so the
only changes we've made on grant street
are a couple of bulges that kind of help
the pedestrian flow in the corners
okay um
counselor go on
to me but i just wondering is there any
um walking
crossings on the east side coming into
the civic building we haven't shown that
street at all
and
yeah if at the moment you sort of have
to walk
you have to walk right down to the
catholic church then across them back in
to get um a crossing for elderly people
coming from the rsa end
yeah look good point
and and there's something we do need to
to think about
we can factor that into the
into the equation as well
okay um so from here
um we take on board those considerations
and include those people and then we go
and talk to
the stakeholders
in general okay thank you
right would somebody like to move those
recommendations thank you council
mcphail seconded councillor
all those in favor please say aye
all right against the motion is carried
thank you
so it brings us to the minutes of the
matera community board
meeting
that need to be received and any
recommendations
contained within them um ratified
so would somebody like to move along
those lines please
you wish i've been happy to answer any
questions that councilman might want
right council phillips move do i have
second after that
council grant thank you
council nick grant
all those in favor please say oh no oh
it's open for discussion now
sorry is there any discussion or
questions
there's not
council guideline
you'll notice um
concerning the zoning of the land
there's going to be a public meeting on
the 30th of may is that right
yeah
that's great it's a workshop you worship
clusters workshop on the 30th that's
right
council read
thank you your worship just a question
for neville if that's okay i'm looking
at the part where the street names are
going to be changed and
well it's under this
under discussion excuse me um the last
the drive is that a correct spelling of
that name or is that a name i haven't
come across before
um
number five the request for street name
changes and the last that's the last
paragraph why happy drive it is a
spelling mistake that's fine yeah that's
good so okay yeah thank you for that
on the name blade it will be dr so
you'll be quite sick
just sorry
sorry
just uh just referring to that it's
under discussion and we're gathering a
bit of information about the
existing names etc and um
a little bit of work has been done
already on that so
waiting for the next community we'll be
having discussions on that
yeah i must admit that um
as a sort of a long-time resident of
matera i've always wondered about
planned parenthood where that came from
so it'll be interesting to
hear a little bit more as to what the
origin of that was
the usher but it's quite an interesting
read from the historical side of um how
plain part got its name so okay yes
very interesting actually
um
brett did you have a question
yeah thanks your worship yeah i just
have a question on the option oh i'm not
liking three options for rezoning and
just not being part of the committee
understanding
the purpose of the letter that was sent
out so the letter that's gone out to
residents that was part of the agenda
here was that just inviting comment as
opposed to formal submissions on on the
plan so
is that clear is that clearly understood
out there or is that perhaps um
i don't never might want to comment but
is it perhaps um
thank you three year worship
uh
yes and i i believe that the letter the
intent of the letter was
as an expression of interest that people
um
it wasn't uh a letter to say that
yesterday we were changing there's only
just a letter of expression of interest
there were thoughts that you may have
etcetera and then you would have had
your opportunity later on with the
council made a decision about rezoning
so i think the
the residents got a little bit misget
skewed about
what the intent was
and i think from the meeting on the the
meeting coming up on the 30th i believe
that everything will be okay
yeah look i think there's there's some
lessons to be learned from for everyone
in this process and and i think the
letter that went out was appropriate but
it would have been good to have some
general publicity
prior to the letters going out that
could have been in the newspapers or on
the radio or whatever so letting people
know that this process is beginning you
will get a letter it will be targeted
and directed to you individually and
then you can
come back and let council know with your
thoughts
so sorry just for the question so that
the the district planning committee
hasn't actually made any decision no on
that it's purely professional absolutely
great thank you
we're just we're just fishing
okay well i think you know i succeeded
and did i say we caught a big fish
that's right it's the most i've ever
seen at a community board meeting and
and i'm very impressed with what the
local residents and how they've got
together
and i'm just hoping in the future that
they
do likewise and keep keep up the good
work
okay
is there anything further
from that set of minutes that council
wants to
examine
if not i'll put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
so that brings us on to item eight which
is um a review of
uh by local policy which was requested
by council uh
dixon i think at the last meeting
so we have a report from the chief
executive
and do you want to speak to that steve
excuse me your worship just
i've got a conflict with this oh yes so
how would you like to me
i'm happy for you to stay
at the desk if you want to if you if you
feel more comfortable removing yourself
from going to the back of the room or
going outside then
i do yeah thank you
you do too yeah
okay
okay steve
yeah worship i took a bit of time to
just think about the buy local policy
and really the
what has transpired since we put in
place the current policy setting in july
2020
because at that time there was
grave concern internationally and within
new zealand about
what would happen to the country and the
aftermath of the
covert 19 pandemic
and you saw at that time there were
the government generated the shovel
ready fund
there was extensive support for business
there's predictions that house prices
before by 15 percent
uh these predictions unemployment would
rise to um
levels not seen since uh 1990 1991
and of course all those predictions
proved to be completely wrong
and
i do wonder whether
as we are working our way through this
albeit painful process of omicron
and now that the borders have opened
partially and will be opened fully in
october
whether
we
alter
the playing field further in favor of
local business
in response to what may just be a
short-term
painful albeit very painful period for
some
but then create
an awkward setting policy-wise that may
need to be further corrected when
some semblance of normality economically
returns
so
it just
it didn't really
sit very well with me to just quickly
adjust
my local policy in response to what all
the experts are saying is a
vicious peak
and a quick fade as well
so
my
my
recommendation is that you
leave the settings as they are
and as i said in the report even if you
adjust the settings
would that actually result in upswing in
business for for locals given that a lot
of the reasons why the cbd particularly
is quiet is people are reluctant to get
outdoors and be in confined spaces
because of the health risk involved
that may well change in a few months as
the omicron
variant
starts to
decrease
and that coupled with
borders being fully opened in october um
it's from this vantage point it may seem
that um
there will be an uplift um
in perhaps four five six months time and
that's that's the way i saw it but i may
be completely wrong you know thank you
um
steve i this is always a difficult one
to balance when we're reviewing this
particular
process you know we want to make sure
that we've got an environment that's
friendly to do business in and that
and that the locals get the first stab
at whatever the council business might
be at a good rate but then against that
we've
got to balance the interest of
ratepayers who are paying the cost of
that so just getting it right can be a
little bit tricky but certainly good to
have the discussion and to review it
from time to time now
council dixon glenis you raised this
last meeting i think do you want to make
any comment at this stage
uh you're on mute clintus sorry
i know australia's a long way away
thank you worship i raised this issue
because i did get some concern for the
community because our retailers and
service centers and their farmers keep
registering commercial revivals
and they keep um buildings in the cbd
i think the town has been notably quiet
and that's been noticed by a lot of
people
i'm unsure about whether changing a
procurement policy would help or if the
administration policy could be reviewed
giving local people the opportunity to
match some of the out of town quotes
or come within a 100 percentage
difference
i think it also would be good for
council to know just how much
council funding is spent in the local
businesses annually
some of the retailers commented to me
that council has not utilized their
business really for some time
and i also think that our rightness
would have more sympathy and spending to
keep our town vital than some of the
other costs incurred by council
i just would like um
so what would you suggest there glennis
i just think there needs to be more
opportunity for local people to
quote or come within
the percentage different so i understand
about the tendering process that you
can't do that
but if quoting for
some of the retailers if they knew that
they their quotes were being
beaten by out-of-towners if they could
work would then come to some
um come up with a difference in that
percentage rating
okay look thank you glennis so open for
discussion
councillors any thoughts
on this one
you know uh
because i hosted then council macphail
just just a question
how practical would it or how difficult
would it be to
gather the spend mobile spin is that a
is that a push of a button or is that a
is that a line by line for the finance
thing that they don't really need to do
with my
scale of doing it and again is can that
be putting their hands in a
appropriate way
yeah through your worship
there would be a little bit of work
involved with that um and it'd be
understanding which where there's a
segment in particular that you're
looking for i do know that we do use a
lot of local businesses for
servicing and things like that we see
the invoices come through on a regular
basis i think i suspect some of the
retailers in question would be
the likes that we don't normally spend
with so things like your neck next doors
or your clothing stores who we wouldn't
spend with anyway so it would be good to
get an understanding of if there's a
sector in particular because we can
tailor tailor that to that but we do
have
uh quite a number we have 700 invoices a
month come through i know three waters
use um mycos locally they use houses
locally they use um
quite a lot of local business uh we're
using local car
carters and stuff for tyres so there is
a lot of a lot of service and and stuff
going back into into the locals
yeah okay thank you um
richard you had a question
look um just through your honor uh
worship the um i'm quite happy with the
recommendation there um around that
sliding scale that currently exists
um then would um put that motion forward
but i believe that probably there should
be a shorter date review on it than
we've had two years
i think that the current environment
we're heading into as you've said
you know
five or six months um
we have got some major changes probably
coming with ocr and interest rates and
we still don't know what's going through
the borders so i don't know whether we
put it through and actually revert
within six months or maybe a year a
12-month review and
and take it as is read so i'd be happy
to recommend it
under those provisions but with a
12-month review not a two-year review
okay
um look i
i can hear what you're saying and i tend
to agree with
that process
it is a pretty rapidly changing
situation we we find ourselves in um
council macdonald
i've only spoke spoken to one retailer
about how his business is going he said
he's going fine there's not many people
in the shop but the people who come in
come in to buy something and they buy it
and go they say he hasn't got
numbers in the shop but his business is
still turning over the same same as he
did previously
okay
any other counselors want to make any
comment at all um
so
counseling failed you're um you're
moving an amendment well you're not
actually moving an amendment to the
motion because there's no emotion yet
but you're suggesting that the
recommendation should contain within it
a um
a review course for 12 months time
okay
so
if you're moving that motion do you
want a second thank you council phillips
is there any further comment before i
put the put the motion glennis do you
want to make any comment
um
yes heaven forbid your worship um just
to make it clear it may be of some help
to some councillors and reviewing the
policy what we can do is bring together
some statistics about the buy local
levels that we have engaged with in the
previous 12 months say so you can get a
feel for how effective the current
policy is
okay if there's no further comment i'm
going to put that motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors um
right item nine and we have a financial
report an update uh for the 31st of
march
and i think we have a a
in addition um a slight change to the
report
burn your hands one eye do you want to
talk us through this
thank you your worship um there's just
one paragraph that's been added to to
the report and it's in the summary
um so what we've got for the year to
date to march uh 2022 is a favorable
variance of 218 000
when you compare that to budget it looks
like we're unfavorable by 3.15 million
but all this is to do with the timing of
our capital subsidies for the shovel
ready projects in the library and
also with with the roading and the the
bridge across the matada which has been
delayed we had budgeted for funding to
come through and the timing of that has
impacted severely
our unfavorable variants if we take
those capital subsidies out and look at
it operationally what we're really
looking at is a comparison of 218 000
versus a budget of 250k so we are
tracking quite comfortably to to the end
of march
despite some ups and downs
so that's the overall that's the overall
picture
you will note that the we council is
under is experiencing the same pressures
as other organizations and other
businesses we are seeing the impacts of
supply chain issues and inflation
particularly in our areas of three
waters and materials and chemicals
materials we're experiencing 30
experiencing a 30 increase in costs and
chemicals that's around about 20
um added to that the vacancies we've had
within the organization the work still
needs to be done so in a lot of areas we
have had to plug the gaps with
consultants
what we're finding now is you know we
are now getting good staff on board and
have we've had a good
number of staffs done in the last few
weeks and what we'll see over the next
week is those consultancy expenses will
come down going forward
um and in line with having staff on
board to cover to cover those roles
it's just a reflection of how
how lean we have been and how how we've
had to try and just keep the council
ticking over
um
oh we've had i guess one of the other
areas we've had we've had a couple of
really interesting um cases and again
we'll talk talk about the bridge um
the appeal on the bridge uh all requires
legal costs to
to um
to appear to i guess
conduct yourselves in those hearings um
and so that that kind of thing has added
to our costs going forward so
each time one of these items comes up we
have we have to defend it and in the
courts and then appeal hearings and
that's i think
i'm happy to take
take some questions okay
councilman mcdonald
i understand you're changing the
variance around to only 250 okay 250k
again
232
but
the all these expenditures here the 2.68
million basically the operating
expenditure so
our operating budget
are we heading for a major deficit
2.86 2.686 million in operating
expenditure capital i never mix capital
and revenue budgets we mix them in
council
so are we heading for a major deficit at
the end of the end of june
through your worship i i don't believe
we are heading for a major deficit
it's
when we track most of our expenses
against um against budget yeah we do
have places where we have savings um
there's a number of departments that
have had again head vacancy so we've got
savings in there there are
some maintenance works that haven't been
undertaken as yet so there is there is a
number of places where we do have
savings that will offset the additional
expenditure
thank you um do you want to make any
comment steve
yeah just to endorse what uh lornae has
said
we've as part of preparing for the
forthcoming
annual plan
workshop which will be on thursday we've
been looking a lot at our existing
expenditure
uh and the trends of all that and
despite the
some lumpiness in some errors uh it's
still tracking around about where it
should be so i i'm not seeing any signs
that we're heading for some
uh big deficit that
perhaps councilman is worried about
great thank you
okay open for other councillors any
questions or queries
with regard to council phillips
thank you russia i just got a question
for matt in regards to the
chemical chemicals and i know
it's for the new water plant and
the supplier
i presume our hands are strong and we
want to ship around for chemicals is
that correct
through your worship
um yes so
i guess
as
the chief financial officer mentioned we
have had a reasonable
cost increase um
in chemicals um
about 20
um the other thing that that's affecting
that is we do see quite an increase
in chemical consumption depending on
the river conditions um
with our wastewater treatment plant so
when the when the river flows are lower
for a longer period of time which we've
had this summer we need to treat our
wastewater to a higher quality which
results in increased chemical
consumption
i guess we have two main chemical
suppliers that we use at the moment
and those cost inflations have been um
more or less the same for both of those
suppliers so
but yeah it's obviously something that
we review in terms of um
whether we're getting uh competitive
pricing for our chemicals
okay
um counselor heisted
oh sorry oh council grant sorry
um
[Music]
um
through your worship yes so um the way
that works is is it's on a
cost recovery basis
um so and it sort of i guess is one of
the reasons it creates a bit of um
lumpiness in the in the budgets um
during this time of year but essentially
um at the end of the financial year we
go through and do a um a review of what
what it's cost to operate the
the industrial hub for the past 12
months um
and then we do a wash up and um and
if if we've overcharged um then we give
a refund or if we're under charge we um
we claim additional costs um so that it
it's always
yeah so that we never lose money on it
okay
right counselor
your thanks your worship um
you're just through you i guess i'd like
stuart i am struggling to reconcile the
expenditure
unfavorable variance to 2.6 million but
i guess
i do have my own the fact that we're
budgeting for an annual surplus of 4.1
million so i guess the question to staff
is i guess i'm likely to achieve a
surplus of 4.1 million but i guess on
from that is understanding why we
budgeted that surplus and you may not be
able to answer on the spot now but
that's probably the part i'm interested
in
yeah through your worship i can
definitely answer that question we
we won't reach the 14.1 million that 4.1
million includes the subsidies we had
budgeted receive for the bridge across
matara so the ncta funding for that
which is a significant amount um we had
anticipated or we had been advised by
the project team that we that we should
budget for that in this year
um and the other one is again the timing
of of the chevrolet project library next
door and the funding on that so
we have
we've budgeted for
1.7 million on that and given the timing
where that's at and when we can claim
um our milestones
uh you know there's a there's been a bit
of slippage in the time frame of of that
project so it means that the ability to
claim those milestones shifts
so entitlement for the next council
meeting i can or for audit and risk
meeting i can take those out and show
you what the real
real one would look like which is which
is part of the reason why i took it out
and said operationally this is what
we're looking like okay thank you that's
a good explanation thanks
okay
other questions or comments from
councillors um if not will somebody like
to move that these um
this
set of uh agenda be uh received
thank you councillor heisted seconded
councillor mac to now
thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against emotion is carried thank you
right we'll move on then to item 10
and we have a proposal around green
waste
one that's been
floating around for some time and
i've had it um reminded to me a number
of times by um
some of our residents that we need to
get this sorted
so uh it's in front of us as a council
to consider now and we've got a report
from lunai
do you want to talk us through this
report renee and how we got to this
point
yes thank you worship and through your
worship um
this has been
a hot topic for a number of months and
has popped up in previous council
meetings
um
the work the majority of the work um
performed on this report was actually
done by a
previous writing manager uh peter
standring and peter and i worked on the
last little bits of it before he
departed to to get this report in front
of you today
effectively
what we wanted to get across to council
was councillors was that the cost of
operating or
processing the green waste at the
at the transfer station is 114 000
around 114 000 a year
to recoup this
we you know we need to be charging
um
a certain level of
i guess green waste to be able to
recover those costs
what we had done is we had
looked at at what point um
what weight point we could get to for
that to be recovered and and we sit
according to looking at the table um
we reached that point somewhere between
200 and 250 kgs of green waste
and saying that we do have a couple of
caveats on that
what we were trying to do was to find a
a scheme that was ease was equitable
was easy to follow easy to administer
for the transfer station staff and they
would take out in the ambiguity what we
were finding is that with four different
staff working in the transfer station
there was a different judgment on what
they considered a load and what not and
where to charge so it's been a lot of
inconsistency so what we were trying to
do with this report was bring in a point
at which green race is free up to a
certain weight and then after that it is
charged per kg or per 100 kg
so i guess what what we wanted to put
before council was whether they wanted
whether you wanted to recover minimum
the minimum cost of what we've got which
does not include inflation or
recovering any of the long-standing
previous year's debts in this um
this activity or whether to increase
increase a little and find a spot just
higher than 100 kgs to help recoup some
of those previous
previous charges
i'm sorry more than 200 kgs to
recoup those previous charges
so looking again looking at the table um
if if we were to set the limit at 200
kgs 77 of those going to the transfer
station to dispose of green waste would
get it for free
200 kgs of green waste is the equivalent
of 10 loads of
grass clippings for the average
household so the average household has
20 kgs worth of grass clippings every
time they they
mow their lawns so that would be twin uh
10 loads of grass clues that is a lot of
green waste if we set that at 200 kgs
but i'm happy to take some questions
happy to
have some discussion on
what we've got
okay um it is open for discussion
counsellors
i know i spend a little bit of time at
the transfer station and
i know it's
convenient to use
lawn clippings as a measure but actually
the
the amount of lawn clippings that i see
over there is quite minimal there's a
lot of other stuff so it's sort of hard
to get your hand around what what the
weight means but anyway i know it's not
easy and council garden you look as
though you're poised ready to go
just there must be a huge difference
dealing with lawn clippings against um
logs
and um and cost and the lawn company is
really just
it's virtually free you just push it out
and know no cost to the
at all whereas if you have to chip
something it's a huge cost
so then can we differential you know
someone bring out logs you'd have to put
a you need a bigger charge per ton than
someone bringing lawn givings
i don't know i don't correct me if i'm
wrong but i don't know that we get a lot
of logs we do get quite a lot of um
chippable waste though
um but i wouldn't count them as logs
do you want to make a comment
just briefly worship the point to
emphasize the reason one of the reasons
why we've opted for a lower suggested
weight for free is to stop the influx of
out of district people wishing to avail
themselves of a free service
so that's in their mind as well and
often
and going back to laurene's point about
simplicity trying to get to to um or
categorize two different types of waste
i think you'll rapidly get yourself tied
up with knots particularly often people
come in with grass clippings combined
with
other green waste branches and
and what have you so it would be very
difficult for the staff over there to
try and
differentiate between the two and make
therefore make an apportionment
just to add to that so the the cost the
cost that we have included and the tonne
and the cost per tonne
um does include chipping and mulching so
effectively for us to process one tonne
of of green waste whatever it is with
those chippable
grass clippings
it is 120 per ton
so what we're proposing so even if it
was 100 kgs worth of green waste someone
hit that 101 kgs or 100 kgs it's only
going to be 12
to dispose of that of that 100 kg so
it's not it's still not a significant i
mean i do appreciate that we're in tough
times and every dollar does count
but compared to i know other places i
know
for a trailer load in dunedin one of the
places is not the council it's 25 a
trailer load
so
it's still 100 kgs on a trailer is
still quite a big trailer um okay
council phillips then council
thank you but it's got a couple of
questions
in there to 114 thousand is that
including matera transfer station
so there's hunting to score
so what's going to happen to matera
uh through your russia this this um memo
just addresses gore we intend to have a
look at mataldo separately in a future
report
yeah and i think so possibly the fear
that council phillips has is if we don't
include matera in this equation
then matara is going to be inundated
if it's still free
anyway
yeah i just think that uh residents are
going to look at
the opening years mater and say on
sunday i'll just take everything to
matera and just dump it off there
because it's going to be free regardless
of what the weight i've got on my
trailer
and the other
thing that i have concerned with is out
of district people getting them for free
hang on a second this is the gore
district
council resident right powers are paying
for it why should the out of district
people come into our trade and come in
and use their transfer stations for free
i i know we understand that we we need
the green waste
but in time we won't and we're not
recovering its cost now so why should we
have an external cost
and you had some thoughts around how
that might be addressed
well
your restaurant i think that every
ratepayer has a barcode um
is that is that correct everyone every
right perhaps a barcode barcode number
they don't
can they be issued with one dislike the
dog registration
uh through your research every every
rate player has an assessment number um
i mean
you could you could there's various
schemes out there where you could issue
um
disks and stuff or stickers to having
windows and everything but you've got to
weigh up the administration costs of
something like that versus the benefits
that it's going to it's going to bring
yeah
i think
wow
council phillips well thank you
i think the benefit is that i think
that's one of the strategies that
perhaps the waste committee could come
up with in in help
with uh part of our um
our waste reduction within our landfill
and i know that we're only talking about
green waste but it will come the time
when the green waste is not required at
the transfer station because
if its capacity is full what do we do
with it then
and um if we're stuck in a time slot
that we can't get ourselves out of but
if we
do it once and do it properly
then we don't have to keep changing it
and and i think the residents
like consistency they don't like
uh chop and changing all the time yeah i
thank you council phillips and i do
appreciate the complexities of this
particular subject particularly where
you might have two sites where
dumping can
can occur
and matera does need to be addressed
and it's something that needs to be
addressed reasonably soon um council
macphail
it's just a couple of comments here
should we worship um
firstly the uh the chipping and the wood
issue
having spent a bit of time over at the
waste station there when we were looking
at the recycling and and different
issues um we did have uh major transport
companies that brought some some serious
logs into air into our um
into waist um area it's stopped now but
uh they did use that free tipping
arrangement and it was noted so
um i think what you've got here is a
practical approach very practical
approach to put a um a baseline
in in play
um the waste committee and the what
neville council phillips is alluding to
is actually about not putting our green
waste away from our land is actually
dealing with it and composting it on on
sections and land
part of that is coming through that
discussion uh so you know that's another
side issue
the other thing is probably a question
for keith um
the
uh chipping that's going on over there
do we put it onto our council gardens do
we put it onto our council land
the um all the chips that are being
dealt with at the dump
where does it go to is it just put into
fill
through your ship i can i can respond to
that one currently the the stuff we have
been using has been used to spread out
in other places across the transfer
station um it has been needed to smooth
out and um
and i guess down near the hamilton park
area as well as being used and around
there so at the moment the what we have
been shipped is being reused within
because it's it's probably one of the
things that will come out in regard to
this that um repurposing um waste
material or or green waste that's going
in is probably the way of recirculating
that recirculating in the community um
and will be part of that project so
um but i support the hundred kilos and
also the fact that it's weighed it gives
clear different definition and some
guidelines to them the staff that work
there they know where the cut-off point
is but i do agree with the fact that it
could go elsewhere
okay um
so we've better this one round a fair
bit over the past few months and i think
that this is a a good start
i think
the point that councillor phillips
raises about matera is one that does
need to be addressed but um it's not
part of this particular equation we're
dealing with
right this minute
and the point that council macphail is
raising about the future of
of waste
and
recycling and repurposing and what all
that looks like is going to be a big
piece of work for this council over the
next few months and i think there are a
lot of opportunities a lot of
opportunities for us to partner with
with other councils with our other
agencies um to make better use of the
waste that we do have
and personally i think a
a depot at the transfer station where
products that are no use to one person
but are still in reasonably good order
can be recycled without it going
anywhere near the
the face
um we need to be
just changing the way that we think
about waste
okay um would somebody like to move the
motion which i think is a four-part
motion is it
um or an amended version of that
dear moving council mcphail
jobs seconder for that council reed
thank you
if there's no further discussion i'm
going to put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
right um
identification of projects for
three waters reform better off funding
package and we have a report here from
the chief executive
on this and steve do you want to just
talk us through this particular
issue
yeah thanks you worship this is part of
the um
funding stimulus or incentive package if
you like that the government has
introduced
uh to assist councils in
their
progress through the three waters reform
package
uh so this is the first tranche
of of 25
of what for this council represents a
nine over nine million dollar package
so
i think it really behooves the council
to think carefully about how it will use
these funds
to get the best possible bang for our
buck
the government is inviting
project or projects plural
to be submitted
for consideration this is a bit
different from what you'd normally
associate with a
discretionary government fund
we are
guaranteed
our funding provided it fits within the
three pronged criteria set out by the
government and listed in my report
so
time is of the essence we've got till
the end of september to submit
a funding proposition and with a promise
that we will get a decision on that um
funding proposal within six weeks
it struck me is that
i think it's a mix it it lends itself to
a mixture of both
officers and elected members and of
course important that we have
representation from the hakuna rinanga
as the government wants to see ewe
involvement and
support for any funding proposal that
emerges
so thinking ahead and looking at a
working party that needs to
have
sufficient detail on a project to make
it
explainable to your your funding source
and then potentially there may be three
or four projects identified and there
may well need to be some prioritization
within those
and then
you have to come back to the full
council
for endorsement or otherwise
and on to
filing the
funding proposal by the end of september
so
those that time will pass pretty quickly
and so
my thoughts were that it would be best
to get a small working party i'm
suggesting four officers because some of
the officers will have
firm ideas about what potential projects
are out there and they need to be then
also overlaid by elected member um
community strategist if you like
to work out where is the
where where the priorities would best
be suited
for this particular community and then
it can actually be
punctuated if you like and a
report back to the council
so don't have any particular
i have one or two perhaps officers of
mine but i suggest you worship that
if you like the idea of a officer
elected member mix
you saw you first work out the ratio and
then perhaps if you'd like to nominate
the elected members
and maybe you like to leave it with
myself as chief executive to nominate
the officers that will actually sit on
that particular working party
look i think the proposal makes sense um
to have that mix
i guess the question would be what
number do we need i'm thinking probably
would need
for good representation from council
probably four
four councillors to be part of that
discussion
and maybe three or four from um
uh the staff and hakanurunga
so that gives us about nine in total i
guess
i think that's workable
how do counsellors feel about that
okay given that
um the time is of the essence we do need
to get things underway i know from my
perspective i would be very keen to be
part of that uh working group i think
this is a real unique opportunity and we
need to make the the most uh of you know
what is on offer
in the most appropriate places so
uh are there any councillors that would
like to be part of that
council mcphail
council heisted councillor reed
um councillor phillips
okay so that's um four or five
okay
we can probably stretch to five
um more the merrier
okay
so if we um
if councillors are comfortable with that
approach then
we need to move along those lines that
we
establish the working party we have that
mixture
as laid out in the recommendation
and that we asked the chief executive to
appoint
staff you counselor heisig
yeah i just was pondering the membership
and thinking that it would be great if
the committee had the ability to
to co-opt a member of the community
um perhaps that community that committee
could identify them it might be a
shifting target in terms of someone with
a particular interest or skill that that
could earn a particular project yeah
yeah good good point yep
and i guess we got to be careful not to
have casts of thousands but we're not in
that realm yet
and
i think that that's a
that's good so everybody's comfortable
with that approach
somebody like to move along the lines uh
counselor read signature counselor davis
um
i'll put that
put that motion
all those in favor please say hi
against the motion is carried
i'm not sure
okay um
look i think that brings us to the end
of the open section of the of the
meeting
and as such
i would
move the exclusion of the public
and that they be excluded from the
following parts of the proceedings of
this meeting namely the items listed
below